hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everybody that submitted questions on my
Game of Thrones video this week now that
we've gotten through Star Wars business
we can get back to Game of Thrones
there's actually been some some really
cool stuff happening on this set they're
just they're circling back around and
doing plots that they skipped in season
five I'm gonna try to avoid as many big
spoilers as possible there been a lot of
pictures from this set mostly surprising
things because there are certain areas
where they film scenes that take place
in vastly different locations in A Song
of Ice and Fire like last year a lot of
the Doran scenes were shot in Spain in
some of those areas doubled for places
where they shot Daenerys as scenes it's
just a way for the production team to
maximize efficiency so the other day I
saw this picture of Cersei which I'm not
gonna post here just because it might be
kind of spoilery it was short hair
talking to a character that she had no
business talking to this early in the
story just to give you guys like a broad
idea like if you really want to read the
books and you're not sure what to read
before season six just go back and read
book four read a feast for crows don't
still be some minor changes to the plot
but it actually see it seems like
they're gonna be changing Jamie's story
less then they changed it in season five
like him going to Dorne was a much
bigger change than anything that they
might change in season six so they're
just circling back around you're gonna
see some familiar characters reread book
four you have plenty of time oh and a
lot of you guys have asked me about like
the potentially leaked scripts I've
tried to avoid those because they're
kind of circumspect but like I said
they're circling back around and
grabbing a lot of old book plots that
they skipped over so those things you
know in those leaked scripts or
potentially scripts I think those are
the true things the other things are
wildly speculative so I'm not really
intending on doing a special video just
for those leaked scripts because they
could just be complete fanfiction but on
to questions here we go just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far
next question miss Lim asks I wanted to
ask you which character do you think is
def gonna make it to the end after all
the wars are over well I mean I
definitely think that Sansa is gonna
make it just because she seems like the
kind of character who's getting that arc
where they overcome struggle and become
this fully actualized human being she
has a long way to go they really drug
her through the mud in season five so
hopefully we started to see her act with
some more agency in season six but
generally I do think that Jon Snow
Daenerys will crawl out alive I mean Jon
Snow isn't gonna die once then come back
just to die again
and I would be really happy to see
Cersei Jaime and Tyrion live Tyrion
tends to be a lot of people's favorite
characters with good reason he's an
amazing character but Cersei is just
getting more and more interesting the
crazier she gets I just I cannot wait to
see where she goes but your questions so
big it's really hard to say like every
single character there's so many
characters in A Song of Ice and Fire
really I think the funniest thing the
funniest example of a character
surviving like just being the cockroach
that won't die would be Walder Frey he
just out lives everyone he's already one
of the oldest characters in the kingdom
just being super super evil just being
the worst person imaginable next
question Jonathan asks speaking of the
Danes do you think there's any
possibility that John isn't a Targaryen
I mean I know the books in the show hit
it hard
what about John is the sword of the
morning Don seemed to fit well with azor
Ahai imagery the only weird part is that
it assumes John giving up Longclaw which
is weird and then number 2 do you think
that there's any credence to the theory
that the White Walkers and the great
other are related to or serve the old
gods or do you think that the old gods
and the Lord of Light are in opposition
since Melisandre in the Bloodraven seem
to espouse such different views on
darkness and light well first question
first I I do think that John is the son
of Rhaegar and Lyanna so I do think he's
a Targaryen but george RR martin did say
that dawn the actual sword is waiting at
Starfall for the nyx sword of the
morning to arise I don't think that John
is gonna lose Longclaw anytime soon so I
think that will be the sword that he
fights with so I think that that's just
leaving room for another sword of the
morning to come along I think that John
fits nicely into that prince who was
promised prophecy he fits a lot of
descriptions that the character seems
like it's surfacing like there's aura a
high character but I don't think that
like every mysterious person that's
supposed to come along in the narrative
is gonna be Jon Snow I still kind of
think the idea that azor Ahai and
Lightbringer are more metaphorical
things like even if the red god imbues
Melisandre with with the energy to
resurrect Jon Snow like even if he makes
that possible really he's just selecting
Jon as a person of interest in the
history of planet os-- does like
Thoreau's Amir was able to resurrect
Barrack like yeah Barrack wasn't
necessarily azor Ahai I just think that
it's a title that gets passed down like
there's no one sword that is like the
ultimate sword in the books right now
the leading candidate to come back and
take Don you know become the next sword
of the morning
is heed Rick Dane the show hasn't done
him yet so it could totally cut dawn out
of the storyline like you could totally
cut this house Dane out of the storyline
not including any Arthur Dayne
flashbacks to answer your second
question though I do think that some
gods are the same God like the
many-faced God is also probably the
stranger that there's probably some
overlap with different people
interpreting different gods in different
ways supernatural creatures exist magic
exists so it stands a reason that some
of these gods actually exists although
I'd be willing to bet that some of them
are probably false not including the
great other in the red God I do think
that there are two separate entities
it'd be kind of cliche if they turned
out to be the same God like different
aspects of the same God so until we get
more evidence from George R Martin in
the books I'm choosing to think of the
red God is his own entity that exists in
opposition to the great other who's his
own entity who they both exist in
opposition to the old gods I think of
the old gods as being more of like gods
of nature in general like you would
worship the planet but I think a George
R Martin will probably spell this out in
wins a winter and dream of spring in
greater detail most of that information
will probably have to come from people
like the Bloodraven like highly learned
people that you know I've lived for a
long time or like the children of the
forest next question though Matthew asks
do you think that Don will ever reappear
in the books or on the show it'll it'll
definitely repair in the books on the TV
show I think we'll probably only see it
in a tower of joy flashback next
question Ethan asks unrelated to Jon
Snow's parentage do you think that the
children of the force could play a part
in the future war to come with the White
Walkers uh yeah I would definitely say
yeah they were a big part of ending the
long night the ones that are still alive
will probably help out the way the war
for the dawn is being sold you know even
though we've gotten hints of it from
Melisandre and we just seen the first
big battle with the White Walkers I
think it's going to be a wart that's
going to involve the entire planet
although most of its gonna take place in
Westeros just because that's where the
White Walkers are but the way the books
explain the children of the forest in
present-day is that that their numbers
have greatly receded they're slowly
dying off it's kind of like the elves
Elrod's people going to the Grey Havens
during Lord of the Rings they slowly
leave this place they kind of transition
to this otherworldly life
next question Oh Frank asks is it likely
that Jon being a Targaryen won't matter
he's probably gonna rule the north after
his legitimization well we don't
necessarily know that he's been
legitimized I think everybody's talking
about you know Rob Rob Starks will maybe
he legitimized John snow but it would
have to happen for that is people would
have to acknowledge that in a public way
I don't think that it even be necessary
for him to be legitimized for people to
rally behind him I think once the Lords
of the North that hate the Bolton's find
out that Jon Snow survived death he's
still alive and Sansa's on the run they
would look to him to rally a force to
get rid of the Bolton's we know a little
finger has an interest in the north he
definitely wants to use the forces of
the Vale to help get rid of the Bolton's
but it sounds like the north is largely
going to be taking care of itself
so if Jon led a successful campaign I
don't think that they would just kick
him to the curb they they would probably
like okay now you get to take over
Winterfell they would either mutually
acknowledge him as a stark or if they
wanted to go the legal route they would
compel Tommen to legitimize him I mean
if Jon really wanted to he could name
himself the next king of winter and just
you know tell anybody to screw off if
they didn't like it like what are you
gonna do you come up here I'm
essentially unkillable they tried in the
red God brought me back what are you
gonna do about it I think Jon
potentially being a Targaryen just gives
him more legitimacy in the eyes of the
other nobles of Westeros they're like oh
he comes from royal blood and he's
unkillable maybe we should listen to
what he has to say I think it'll just be
easier for him to rally support next
question Danny asks there's a fan theory
that a Shara's kid is Daenerys not Snow
I think fueled by the fact that sir
Barristan thinks of a shara when he sees
Daenerys his eyes because they both had
purple eyes george RR martin might be
throwing us off a little bit and then
you say dawn is made from a meteorite
i've never encountered a space rock that
would make a sword milk-white and then a
long time question how do the show's
writers justify marrying Sansa to Ramsay
since Tyrion is not even rumored dead
even based on non-consummation shouldn't
an annulment of her first marriage have
been produced at some point to make her
second marriage legal does Littlefinger
have the power to do that okay all great
questions so I'm gonna start with the
first one first there are definitely a
lot of coincidences but I you know I
think especially with eyes there's just
a lot of people that share some common
DNA so I do think that Daenerys is still
the daughter of the Mad King that you
know that's why they're trying to make
her seem like she was going a little bit
crazy during season five like maybe
she's gonna set the entire city on fire
like her father tried to do once with
her dragons so even though the TV show
changes a lot from the
they definitely try to allude to the
same things that the books are alluding
to like you know headed in the same
direction so I haven't seen any
compelling evidence that Daenerys is the
child of anyone else but the Mad King
but that's taking the text of the book
in taking the show both into context if
you go just based on book evidence you
tend to produce different theories than
if you include the stuff that the show
is done for your second question about
Don being the glowing space-rock sword
I'm not a scientist but I think that
George are Martin just wanted to make it
a little bit more special so you could
you could say that it has some
supernatural properties you could say
that it's just a space rock that doesn't
exist in real life
I think it's a conceit just to make the
sword seem bigger badder better in about
Sansa and ramsey so Littlefinger
whenever he was talking to the Bolton's
about getting married he said the
marriage was never consummated like you
said in your question I think her
marriage to Tyrion was probably swept
under the rug off-camera it probably
just happened sometime in between
episodes but because all the characters
lie so much you could make the case that
she's still technically married to
Tyrion so you know until they say it on
the show you could argue either way next
question Heather says fire cannot kill a
dragon if Jon Snow's a Targaryen then he
is a dragon and I bet the Nights Watch
will have a hard time burning his body
so I think this is more of an offhanded
remark but I wanted to use it because a
lot of people are always asking about
Daenerys being burnt by fire in the show
changing things from the books
technically Targaryen not being burned
by fire is a myth Georgia Martin
explained that at the end of book 1 when
she walks through the fire and comes out
with the hatched dragons that was blood
magic in place that was but a special
case usually people arguing saying that
Daenerys cannot be burnt by fire say
that she got in a really hot bathtub in
that first episode in the pilot steaming
bath water and flames are two completely
different things Dan and Dave as much as
they changed in the books I think every
once in a while they just want to make
something visually seem really cool and
it's really easy to read too much into
situations like that especially when you
have a character like her brother who
just won't stop talking about how he is
the dragon you don't want to wake the
dragon like he keeps referring back to
dragons the best example in the books of
Targaryen not being immune to fires the
tragedy at Summer Hall were egg from
Dunkin egg in a big portion of his
family all died in a completely normal
fire like a normal house fire and yes I
know Daenerys is standing really
close to drogue on here when he is like
just breathing Jets of fire but I just I
don't think she's standing close enough
to get burnt like where she's standing
closer it would completely cinch her
hair so just based on what George R
Martin has said targaryen can totally be
burnt by fire unless you're invoking
some sort of magic thank you so much
everyone for so many questions these are
always a ton of fun to do and
congratulations to this week's book
giveaway winner MX seal you win a copy
of a night of the Seven Kingdoms just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I get your contact
info so there's still quite a bit of
filming left to do in season six so we
might get some more news from the set
but because they're getting into like
the last couple of episodes they should
be done filming sometime in November and
there was rampant spoilers last year so
I'll try to tiptoe around as many
spoilers as possible but if there's
anything you guys want me to do for my
next bonus video just let me know in the
comments there's a couple other videos
I'm trying to catch up on before the
weekend and I'm still moving to my new
apartment I haven't moved my set yet so
once I do I'll totally do a room to her
video while you guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here to
learn all about Rashard Danes history in
the books and you can click here to
watch the Star Wars trailer again like
five more times thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you